how did the idea of Toy Story 4 and the
development of of this project happen
and who are the people that need to add
to that story obviously I would think
screenwriter but the producers probably
maybe even well Andrew yeah let's start
with Andrew you know understanding who's
written on all the films and kind of the
Godfather one of the godfathers of Toy
Story he he had an idea that will became
a tree a secret treatment that I think
he was writing before 3 even came out
and that's what he told us but nobody
knew he was working on this and in that
idea was the return of Bo Peep and so
that's that's where that idea kind of
started from that was the Nugget of that
idea but it was it was it's worth noting
that the the three of us and before we
roped you guys in we were sort of among
the people at Pixar that were that
questioned it I mean our initial
reaction was well why why would we do
that because three had this beautiful
ending and any part of it was this kind
of poetic and emotional ending parent
toy store has always been sort of a
based on his parental analogy you know
the toys are there for their kids when
they need them and this this is kind of
a story of the the Andy going off to
school felt like this closure and Andrew
what he was working on unbeknownst to us
was a version where he said that's never
been the ending in his head that's
always been the ending of the Andy what
do you relationship but this there's
another chapter and now he's he's
writing this of course as his kids our
kids are a little younger but his kids
had just left to go to school to go to
college and I he kind of was fueled a
little bit by this observation of us as
parents and I think in the first
position was Andrew is what do you do
when you when you've done everything
you've kind of been asked to do he's
done a good job and now you're left to
redefine yourself and was he started
talking about that with us about woody
that became very interested we went from
kind of crossing our arms a little bit
to like sitting forward and going okay
well that is interesting what would he
do what if we could what if we could
pivot woody in a way that would have him
even questioning who he is and what he
does why he does it
that felt movie
and I think that took us to like a
really interesting level to where it was
like woody is questioning his purpose
and then we kind of expanded that out to
like what is our purpose in the world
and that kind of became like the driving
theme a little bit of the movie let us
go for key it's very much an empty nest
story for for woody it's like hey he has
been there for his kid no matter what
was just what he's been saying for three
movies and and now his kid went to
college and it's kind of like now I mean
he's in a new room which was that's the
thing we got me excited about it was
like I know Woody's so well from
watching all his films but now I've
never seen him in this situation before
and that's what was really exciting
about it talk about developing this film
that's that you avin show Andy from the
original Toy Story would say it's nine
years and during the scope of this whole
thing but Andy 25 years ago did not look
like that so what were the challenges of
producing Toy Story 4 with the
technology and the know-how that you
guys have now and at the same time
making it feel like it was Toy Story
yeah yeah with Andy coming back in this
one you know the technology is marched
forward so far that we needed to rebuild
and reshape all the characters to bring
them into the up to code so to speak to
get him in the movie Andy that give us a
chance to kind of upgrade Andy a little
bit if we were to just put the Andy from
the first Toy Story in this one I think
he would have scared audiences the way
that he did back during the first one we
had the chance to make him look a little
bit better so we took advantage of that
we had to put him in a red hat though to
make sure everybody knew it was it was
Andy
but yeah technology its that was the Toy
Story was the first ever animated film
and so it's cut it's been light years
since then and it's in so we had the
chance to put a lot of real rich detail
into this film that we didn't have in
the early days you know we're always
pushing technology to the limits on all
of our films but but now what we're
capable of as a studio and just in the
world is just so much more detail but it
was important to us that it felt like
the original toy story's dead you
weren't pulled out by that new look but
when you think back in your mind's eye
what it was like to be with these
characters in the early films it felt
the same in Toy Story 4 so you're
directing for the first time and you're
directing based on a sequel that was
originally directed by the founder of
the studio and everybody else that so
what woul freaking me out right now yeah
yeah no pressure and and the other part
of it is you were sold director
oftentimes with animation there's two
directors so was that especially
daunting for you or yeah a little bit
okay it was a when I was off for the
chance to do and I've worked at Pixar
for 16 years I'm in the story Department
and wrote on inside I was the head of
story on that thumb as well so I was
close enough to see how it works but you
did you know you never really know until
you're in the driver's seat and
everybody has a million questions for
you and so yeah it was a lot I mean I I
love these characters so much I
experienced the first two films as an
audience member I didn't work at Pixar
yet so I I got to come into this as a
fan but you know there's a lot of it's a
tall order especially after three and
make wanting to make sure it felt like a
story that needed to be worth that
needed to be a exists in existence and
worth telling I recommend for all
first-time directors that you should
have Tom Hanks being your filming that
helps what were the characteristics of
forky that convinced you that this was a
role for you yeah I think I said yes a
little too fast but I went when I came
in the first day they they brought me up
to Pixar which is like a creative
Wonderland and I had never been and they
were so gracious but they just they they
showed me a picture of Fork you know I
was like huh not what I not what I
imagined but just the way that they
described him as being so new to the
universe not really knowing anything of
that you know toys would drop to the
ground he'd just be like what's going on
why are you guys doing this and he was
just such a blank slate and describing
him as really having this childlike
Wonder and armor when my child was fine
years old and she just had questions
non-stop and he was just and he didn't
he he also they just had one route he's
like I help people eat chili and then I
go to the trash and that's that's it
that's that's a wrap so and so the fact
that he would he comes along and says no
you have you have a greater purpose in
that you have value and you know it's
just and actually I will say like
starting out doing about just you know
doing trash different ways and and kind
of the humor of forculus can stuff it
wasn't really until later that this just
beautiful kind of meta message came out
about someone who might see themself as
just having that one direction they've
been told that and that they have a
greater purpose and a greater value
really formed and it's just just
beautiful how it kind of morphed into
that really there's very specific visual
performances sometimes just single eye
blinks very subtle things where you know
what those toys are thinking and you
know what they're feeling and the voices
of course certainly help and give you
the tenor but there's also the
performance and the silence occasionally
that you allow these characters to have
so I just want to talk about your get
hear about your I guess your rhythm and
how you find the ability to allow that
breath I'm glad you're asking about this
because this is one thing I've never
seen in animated films which is letting
the scene just kind of be you know and
and knowing that this film is going to
be about this relationship between Woody
and Beau I knew that we'd be relying
really heavily on our animators and they
are as you could see phenomenal at their
jobs so my and their two actors there
they are they're just as important as
Tom and and Tony and everyone so you
know I'd sit down with him and I walked
them through the scene and kind of go
this is what what he's thinking at this
point he's not saying it but this is
what he's thinking and then both sees
that reaction and she's thinking this
and so we would literally break it down
thought by thought and then the
animators would go away
animate bring it back together we'd
watch it
and see is this is this still tracking
is this is everything you know working
and being an animation it's amazing that
you know nothing is real obviously which
means that you can direct everything so
like for example underneath the car when
they're saying goodbye to each other the
raindrops coming off of what he's had
one of them what's going through his eye
like in front of his eye
so I said let's move that to the side
and have it drip over here and okay yeah
we can do that so you know every single
eye blink every single inhale every
single subtle thing is has been planned
and and talked through the film is kind
of about separation I think in many ways
so I'm just wondering what part of that
did you guys connect with or what what
do you see
what was your through line for your part
of dealing with that theme I think it's
um how a lot for me I mean really
connecting with like Woody's journey and
beau and how it kind of tied together it
was just like this idea of like loss and
how do you redefine yourself after
you've lost something that really
defined your complete identity and your
purpose in life and how do you find
meaning when you have essentially I you
know a little bit like you know his kids
gone you know what would you do with
that after that who do you become when
your entire purpose which is to be there
for that child and you don't know where
you belong in the world anymore and then
you can get into this really interesting
emotional territory and you know Woody
is mourning the loss and Beau has found
a way to redefine herself within that
loss and so she becomes a little bit of
a mentor figure to him which is kind of
a great journey you know in addition to
the separation I think one thing
watching this movie I realized that has
been throughout the entire franchise's
you see this group of characters that
are all incredibly different and they
work together they live life together
woody is constantly saying come on guys
and there's you know buzz and woody
could not be more different and they
there's a celebration of their
differences and they find ways to work
it out and their group and their gang
and they keep going and it's just such a
beautiful example of like yeah that's
how we're meant to live we're meant to
live this life together
you know so Tony you've done other
animation I'm just curious as to how
this process was different or what you
enjoy about voicing and doing voices for
animation yeah I mean Pixar was fairly
unique because typically with other
animation you're kind of separated in a
booth in you there's a piece of glass in
between you and the writers and
directors and you know you kind of do
your thing and then everything goes
silent and you just kind of see them
talking about you and you're just all
the all the insecurities just flushes
over your body but with Pixar you're all
in the same room and so you're in the
same room and you you really feel like
it's a very kind of collaborative effort
which I really appreciate it kind of the
warmth that they they made with that it
was with and with kind of voicing
something it's it's unique because I
mean I look at my character on veep and
it's there's so much physicality and
actually my my character on veep really
wasn't even allowed to speak
it was Selina Meyer wouldn't let me
speak and so I could only use my
nonverbal
eyebrows and all this kind of stuff and
and forkie doesn't even have any
flexibility and she's just a spoon you
know his arms are completely out of
control his eyes don't even have any
control and so it was all the voice you
know was all he that's why he just went
crazy and asked a ton of questions so
it's something that I think just when I
would do it I would just kind of try to
be as silly and then hope it would
channel into the microphone but to speak
to I mean granted I am saying all this
by saying like the voice is so grateful
to do but we are a piece of this pie and
the most of this pie is the artistry and
animation that has gone to this movie
it's incredible and you even look at
four key he seems very very simple but I
was talking to Josh about this and his
textures alone like you have the plastic
of the fork you have the the pipe
cleaners of the arms the googly eyes the
wood of the feet the clay all those
textures are so specific to get right
that is a tremendous amount of work I
mean the the hours of labor that has
gone into this is just unbelievable well
I really thank you all for taking time
out and to talk about the making of this
film